MANOJ JAYADEVAN: Hi and
welcome to the session
"Software-Defined
Networking Meets HPC."
In this session, we'll discuss
how cloud networking and SDN
enables customers to learn
HPC application of scale
on Google Cloud.
High-performance computing is
a foundational infrastructure
for researchers and scientists
for the computations.
And HPC is important.
It's actually much more
evident during these times,
with the COVID-19 pandemic.
For example, scientists in
the life sciences industry
are seeing sudden demand for
the computing needs and are
increasingly turning
towards Cloud technologies
for their computational needs.
We are also observing
the same trend of demand,
I mean, in other areas of
HPC like financial modeling
and weather forecasting.
HPC infrastructure
can be quite complex
and require highly
specialized and very expensive
infrastructure.
With the advent of
cloud computing,
more and more customers are
demanding the flexibility
and agility of the cloud model
for their HPC applications.
So the good news is that HPC
workloads can leverage Cloud,
and Cloud can deliver the
comparable, incomparable,
or better performance metrics
for most HPC workloads.
This quote from Andrew
Sutherland of MIT
sums it up quite well
how cloud computing
can help the HPC application to
do a much better job with HPC.
In this presentation
today, I will
share how Google Cloud can
help with HPC application done
in Cloud and provide
the best experience
and meet your
price/performance objectives.
My name is Manoj.
I'm a Product Manager in
Google Cloud Networking Team.
And I will be
co-presenting this session.
So this talk is
primarily focused
on networking aspects of HPC.
But we'll also be discussing
about other components
of the infrastructure and
services that's required
to run HPC in the cloud.
We will talk about some
specific application benchmarks
that provide insight into the
capabilities of Google Cloud.
Google Cloud offers the
best class infrastructure
to run HPC applications.
Our offerings
provide a broad set
of compute product around
tightly coupled [INAUDIBLE]
workloads, including machine
learning applications
and high-performance
data analytics workloads.
These products are actually
backed by Google's Networking.
And Google's Networking
is the same networking
that is built and designed
to run all of Google's
billion-plus-user services.
The services like Gmail,
services like Maps, service
like Search--
everything runs on the same
infrastructure as Google Cloud.
We will be discussing
this in a lot more details
in the next couple of slides.
Google Cloud platform also
provides a very broad set
of storage
applications that helps
you deploy HPC application
and scale on Google Cloud.
We'll be talking a lot more
about that in this session
as well.
Last but not least, you
have a very broad ecosystem
of partners that helps
us fill the gaps that we
may have in Google Cloud.
Specifically, when you
look at the stack for HPC,
it's actually quite deep.
So things like schedulers
and workload managers--
we have a strong
partner ecosystem that
helps you fill those gaps.
Our success in HPC is very
evident in the broad set
of successful
deployments that we
have across different
verticals like health care,
life sciences, financial
services, education, research,
et cetera.
They run complex HPC codes like
computational fluid dynamics
and better modeling, but create
[INAUDIBLE] on Google Cloud
at very, very high scales.
This list is actually
growing tremendously.
As I mentioned before,
we have a very strong set
of ecosystem partners.
As I mentioned, HPC is
not just infrastructure.
It actually has a stack
that is very, very deep.
So we have a very broad set
of partner ecosystems that
help you fill the gaps that you
might have to have on Google
Cloud, for example, workload
managers and schedulers
and system integration.
So that actually helps
customers to really quickly come
onto Cloud and deploy
their applications
as fast as they can.
Now let's go and have
a very deep journey
into the networking
stack of Google Cloud.
PARVEEN PATEL: In
the next few slides,
we will show you how
Google Cloud uses
the power of
software-defined networking
to deliver high
performance and low latency
on a general-purpose,
multi-tenant cloud
infrastructure.
GCP supports up to 100 Gbps
of bandwidth on a single VM
and delivers latency as
low as 10 microseconds
between two VMs in the same
placement policy group.
So let's get started.
Google was one of the pioneers
of software-defined networking
for both physical networks
and virtual networks.
Google's virtual networking
SDN stack is called Andromeda.
A key aspect of the
SDN architecture
is the separation of the control
plane from its data plane.
The data plane resides
in physical switches,
for example, the edge
routers and end data center,
and virtual switches
like the hypervisor
on every machine in the cloud.
A logically centralized
control plane
has a complete
view of the network
as well as the customer intent.
The controller then
realizes customer intent
across different
data plane elements.
For example, the
Andromeda controller
shown here in this picture
takes a VPC firewall policy,
translates it into appropriate
rules for each host that's
running a VM for
that VPC, and then
distributes that policy
to the virtual switches
on those machines.
An important benefit
of this architecture
is that it scales better and
removes the bottlenecks found
in traditional networking.
For example, it lets us
provide the same VPC features
to VMs, bare-metal
instances, and containers.
The feature that
is most relevant
to high-performance
computing is performance.
And in particular,
the performance
of the virtual switch
that implements
most of cloud networking is
routing and security policies.
So how does Google build
a fast virtual switch?
The Andromeda virtual
switch is built
using a framework called Snap.
Snap enables OS-bypass
packet processing pipelines
and user mode.
Snaps are both running these
pipelines on dedicated threads
or in shared threads.
Andromeda on Snap has two
key components, a fast path
and per-VM co-processors The
fast path packet pipeline
runs on dedicated threads and
has a very small CPU budget,
literally nanoseconds
for every packet.
More expensive pipelines
such as NAT and DoS
protection-- they run
in per-VM co-processors.
So this architecture
neatly enables
us to achieve both high
performance and isolation.
That is one VM's traffic
does not affect another VM.
Software tuning, such
as dedicated threads
and optimizing the number of
instructions for a packet,
can only take you so far.
To get true HPC-class
performance,
hardware offloads have typically
played a critical role.
Andromeda started out
its offload efforts
with simpler offloads such
as TCP segmentation and then
send/receive offloads.
We then added encryption
offload to it,
as it was one of the expensive
components of our packet
processing pipeline.
A recent enhancement which
is very relevant to HPC
is the introduction of
zero-copy payload transfers
between a VM's memory
and the NIC hardware.
Andromeda still gets to
process headers of packets.
And hence, it can continue to
enforce VPC policies and rate
limits.
But there is no
software involved
in the movement of
payload, which helps
us achieve high performance.
So now let's see how
well it works in practice
and what performance
we are able to achieve.
This graph here
shows how performance
has been a big focus of
Google Cloud networking
for many years.
And we've been making continuous
improvements in performance.
Only the last two
bars of this graph
are relevant to current skews.
We're able to hit line rate
of 100 Gbps inside your VMs.
And this is available right
now on GPU-attached VMs.
Other types of VMs
have up to 32 Gbps
depending on the core count.
So with that, we've solved
the bandwidth problem.
What about the harder problem
of latency, which is also
very critical to HPC workloads?
For latency, the entire software
stack, as well as the network
connecting the VMs
play a critical role.
We've looked at
the virtual switch
in the hypervisor at GCP.
Now let's take a look at
what's inside the guest VM
and the rest of the HPC stack.
In this figure, starting at the
very top, are the applications.
Tightly coupled MPI applications
are written to MPI frameworks.
And GCP supports both
Intel MPI and Open MPI.
These frameworks depend on
either directly the Linux
TCP/IP stack, or they
access the networking
stack through libraries
like the libfabric library.
Now, Google has invented many
of the major improvements
to TCP in the last few years.
And we have one of the
best congestion control
teams in the world.
Underneath the TCP stack are
the drivers that interact
with the virtualized NIC.
GCP supports the
generic VirtIO driver.
But recently, we also introduced
our own Google virtual NIC
driver.
This gVNIC device exposes the
best of Google's infrastructure
to the guest OS.
For example, the zero-copy
feature that I talked about
is exposed by the gVNIC driver.
Now, Google has one
of the best performing
SDN-based physical networks
underneath Google Cloud.
But no matter how
good the network is,
one of the important things
you can do to reduce latency
is really place VMs
next to each other.
This is where the
placement policy comes in.
GCP supports two types of
placement policies, compact
and spread.
VMs associated with the same
compact placement policy
are placed very close to each
other in the data center.
So now let's see how well
all this works in practice.
The graph here
shows an experiment
where we run the famous MPI
ping-pong benchmark on Google
Cloud.
The leftmost data point
is the baseline latency
between two VMs without
any placement policy.
And as you can see here, we
get about 28 microseconds.
By choosing the right
VM type, in this case,
the compute-optimized VMs that
Manoj will talk about in a bit,
and associating them with
a compact placement policy,
we were able to get the latency
down to 18 microseconds.
So that's a good
10-microsecond improvement
on the base latency in a zone.
As we tune different
layers of the stack
that I showed in
the last few slides,
we see that latency
continued to improve.
And the bottom
line is that we can
get to under 10-microsecond
latency on Google Cloud today,
which is sufficient for running
some of the most demanding
workloads.
Now, we don't
expect our customers
to make all these
optimizations by hand.
So we've created solutions
guide as well as bat script
that you can run inside your
favorite VM instance types
to activate these optimizations.
So that gives you
a flavor of how
GCP leverages SDN to build
the right network for HPC.
This SDN-enabled network
gives you low latency and high
throughput.
Your MPI traffic can
leverage VPC features
like the VPC firewall.
And since all of this
is built via software
on general-purpose
infrastructure,
high-performance networking
is available on many instance
types, both general purpose, as
well as compute-optimized VMs.
Now let's take a look at compute
and storage infrastructure.
MANOJ JAYADEVAN: Now that we
understand a little bit more
about the networking magic that
connects everything together,
let's talk a little
bit more about what
other components of
the infrastructure
is required to meet
HPC applications
such as from Google Cloud.
Google Cloud actually offers a
broad set of compute products
that can suit all kinds of
applications starting from web
servers and network
appliances, and of course,
large-scale tightly coupled
MPI and [INAUDIBLE] workloads.
The general purpose instance
is called N2 series or N2D
machines.
They actually balance
price and performance
that are suitable for most
workloads that you may have.
But we have specialized
compute-optimized VMs,
called the C2 instances, that
offer high-end vCPU performance
for HPC applications.
We'll talk a little bit more
about the C2 instance type
in the next slide.
We also have a
memory-optimized VM type,
called M2, that is
actually suitable
for your memory-intensive
applications like I said,
[INAUDIBLE].
For lower TCU app-- again,
TCU is actually very, very
important for HPC because,
as I mentioned before,
a HPC infrastructure
can be quite expensive.
So cost is very important
for a lot of customers.
So for customers like that, we
offer the preemptible VM types.
If your applications are
designed as a [INAUDIBLE]
application and can withstand
possible preemptions,
then the preemptible instance
type can save up to 80%
of your time--
of your savings.
We also provide the best
accelerator actually in Cloud,
including the NVIDIA GPUs and
Google innovations like tensor
processing units to speed
up your applications
and give you faster
time results.
Now let's talk a little bit
about the compute-optimized VM
or the C2 instance types.
Compute-optimized VMs are well
suited for HPC application,
as I said before, both
tightly coupled applications
and high-throughput
applications.
Compute-optimized instances
offer high-end vCPU performance
for compute workloads
and offer up
to 40% more performance compared
to your general purpose VMs.
They also leverage the
second generation Intel Xeon
processors and can run
at a sustained clock
speed of about 3.8 gigahertz.
Additionally-- this is actually
a very important point--
C2 VMs can provide
full transparency
to the architecture of the
underlying server platforms.
The NUMA topology is actually
exposed to the guest operating
system.
And then applications can
actually make smart choices
to use the NUMA topology.
This actually improves
the performance a lot.
You can choose a C2 instance up
to 60 vCPUs and 250 gigabytes
of memory and attach up to 3
terabytes of local storage.
C2 instances can also
deliver up to 32 Gbps
of [INAUDIBLE] throughput rate
for the Light CPU configuration
type.
And we have a very
strong roadmap
to basically improve this.
And you can actually expect
those high performance
throughput instances
to be on C2 instances.
What we are observing is HPC and
machine learning infrastructure
are undergoing a convergence.
We are actually seeing more and
more machine learning workloads
now using the HPC platform.
GPUs are hence becoming a
very integral part of HPC.
GCP actually offers
high-performance GPUs
on Google Cloud for
machine learning,
scientific computation,
and 3D visualization.
GPUs can actually be added
to your VM instance type.
And these VM instance types
are highly configurable.
You can attach storage,
memory, bandwidth.
And it actually acts like
a regular VM for you.
But you can attach it to eight
GPUs for these instance types.
GPUs will also work
with the GKE clusters.
And GPU will always foll--
it will also work with
your preemptible VMs,
which is actually a very
common use case for HPC and ML.
Now, one very important point
that I would like to make
is we have a really strong
partnership with NVIDIA.
And that actually helps
us bring GPUs that--
the latest and the greatest GPUs
that basically NVIDIA comes out
with on our platform
as fast as we can.
Today, we support
the Tesla platform.
And in the future, we are--
in the very near future,
will be supporting the
NVIDIA's Ampere platform.
From a bandwidth
standpoint, we actually
deliver up to 100 gigs on
certain GPU types today.
And this is actually in beta.
But we have a very, very
strong roadmap coming up.
And you can expect that
the higher throughput--
that feature is
very, very important
for the HPC-- is
going to be showing up
for these GPU machine
types in the near future.
Now, cost is actually very
important for customers,
as we mentioned before, right?
So we have various programs
and various options
that's available for customers.
For example, with preemptible
VM types, as I mentioned before,
you can actually save
up to 80% of your cost.
We also offer strong,
deep discounts
for committed and
sustained users.
You could actually
save up 30% to 55%
depending on how long you
are using the VM instances.
Now let's talk a little bit
about the storage support
on GCP.
Storage is also very important.
It's very complex.
And as I mentioned
before, the requirements
for HPC application's
actually quite broad.
Storage requirements for HPCs--
they're very similar to what
any other regular enterprise
application, but with
some exceptions, right?
Google Cloud Platform delivers
various storage offerings
like SQL, NoSQL, blog and
blog, and what have you.
It's a broad set of offerings.
But for-- we have some offering
that very specifically designed
for HPC.
For example, we have object
stores and file stores
and a [INAUDIBLE]
compliant [INAUDIBLE]
file system that is very
widely used in the HPC space.
But the very first step that
a customer normally takes
is, how do I move my data from
on-premise to Google Cloud?
So for that, we actually
offer a service called TSOD.
Customers can use this service
to hydrate their Google Cloud
storage systems from on-premise.
GCS, or the Google Cloud
Storage system, is our--
the Google Cloud's object store.
And a lot of customers actually
use this as primary storage.
And a lot-- the
other customers use
this for archival
storage on Google Cloud.
We also have a broad
set of [INAUDIBLE],,
but Google-managed
and partner-managed.
Cloud Filestore is
our NFS file system.
And the capacity that we
offer today is about 60 TB.
We have also announced
the Filestore High Scale
offering, which can actually
scale up to 325 terabytes.
Customers also have the option
to use EMC or NetApp if they
choose that as their option.
Now, HPC customers who
are running tightly
coupled applications or
MPI applications-- they'd
normally require a [INAUDIBLE]
compliant [INAUDIBLE] system.
So GCP has partnered with
a company called DDN.
And jointly, we basically
provide an offering
on Google Marketplace.
But they can actually use
Lustre as their file system
that has very high
[INAUDIBLE] ops
and scales horizontally
for the HPC needs.
So to sum it up, customers
can deploy the rights
to a system for the
main application
and get the best possible TCO.
Now let us see how all
these things come together
in our next few slides.
PARVEEN PATEL: So
now that we gave you
a glimpse of the
building blocks needed
to build an HPC solution,
we'll take a look
at two specific workloads.
The first workload is a
weather forecasting workload.
It's a benchmark that many
customers run on premise
on their state-of-the-art
dedicated InfiniBand clusters.
The first line on this
graph shows the performance
some customers get on premise--
faster completion,
which is-- you
know, lower value is
better in this case.
The second line shows how
this workload performed
on GCP without many
of the optimizations
we talked about today.
Once we applied
these optimizations
that we discussed plus some
workload-specific tuning,
we were able to not only
match the performance
the customers get on
premise, but we did it
with 30% fewer CPU cores.
Now, there are
additional optimizations
that we have not shown
in this graph that
can bring down the
completion time even further.
But you're not always
shooting for lowest
latency, but the best
price/performance
ratio for your workload.
And this workload,
this benchmark,
demonstrates that really well.
Let's also look at
the LS-DYNA workload.
This is a well-known workload
in the automotive industry
that does crash simulations.
This workload is
notoriously tricky to scale.
The two graphs here show
two different configurations
of this workload.
As you can see that with the
help of the optimizations
that we discussed
today, this workload
scales quite well up to multiple
hundreds of cores on GCP.
This is as good as
what our customers are
able to get on premise on
a dedicated, specialized
infrastructure.
We looked at many
such workloads.
We only discussed these two.
And what we find is that for
each workload and a given data
set, there is a
sweet spot in terms
of price/performance ratio.
Once you have the
right set of tools,
you can easily find that
sweet spot and provision
and pay for just
enough infrastructure
for your workload.
And Cloud lets you make
that trade-off which was not
even possible on premise.
So in summary, we
would like to leave you
with three key messages.
You know, one is
that you no longer
need to pay for a dedicated,
specialized infrastructure
to run HPC workloads.
Google Cloud makes
available to you
the best-in-class
infrastructure and we
use to run our own
high performance and AI
machine learning workloads.
Anyone can get access to
this infrastructure on demand
and pay only for what they use.
Number 2, HPC is a huge
area of investment for us.
We built a number of solutions
for various industry verticals,
and new ones are being
added to it every day.
Number 3, if you don't see
your workload listed here,
please do let us know.
We want to make sure
that Google Cloud is
the best at running all kinds
of high-performance computing,
as well as high-performance
data analytics workload.
Thank you.
MANOJ JAYADEVAN: Thank you.